now that we've set up our surface
integral we can attempt to parameterize
the surface and one way to think about
is we want our x and y values to take on
all of the values inside of the unit
circle what i'm shading in right over
here and then our z values can be a
function of the y values we can express
this equation right here z is equal to 2
minus y and then we can figure out how
how high above to go to get our z value
and by doing that we'll be able to
essentially get to every point that sits
on our surface
and so first let's think about how we
can get every x and y value inside of
the unit circle and so let me
let's just focus on the x y plane we're
kind of rotated around a little bit so
it looks a little bit more traditional
so this is our
this is my x-axis
and then my y-axis
would look something like that let me
draw a little bit different this is my
y-axis
y-axis and then if i were to draw the
unit circle so kind of the base of this
thing or at least where it intersects
the xy plane
and actually this thing would keep going
down if i wanted to draw the x squared
plus y squared equals one but if i draw
where it intersects the xy plane
it is we get the unit circle so let me
just draw it
so we get that's my best attempt at
drawing a unit circle we get the unit
circle we need to think of using
parameters so that we can get every x
and y coordinate that's inside of the
unit circle and to think about that i'll
introduce one parameter that's
essentially the angle with the x-axis
and i'll call that parameter theta
so theta is the angle with the x-axis
and so theta will essentially sweep
things all the way around so theta can
go between 0 and 2 pi
so theta will take on values between 0
and 2 pi
and if we just fix the radius
at some point say radius 1 that would
only give us all of the points on the
unit circle but we want all the points
inside of it too so we need to vary the
radius as well so let's introduce
another parameter let's call it r
that is the radius so for any given r if
we keep changing theta we would
essentially sweep out a circle of that
radius and if you change radius a little
bit more you'll sweep out another circle
and if you vary radius between 0 and 1
you'll get all of the circles that will
fill out this entire area so the radius
is going to go between 0 and 1. another
way of thinking about it is for any
given for any given theta if you keep
varying the radiuses you'll sweep out
all the points on this line and then as
you change theta it'll sweep out the
entire circle so either way you think
about it so with that let's actually
write
let's actually define x and y in those
terms so we could say that x
x is equal to
x is going to be equal to so the x value
whatever r is the x value is going to be
r cosine
r cosine theta it's going to be that
component it's going to be r
cosine theta and then the y component
this is just basic trigonometry is going
to be the y is just going to be r sine
theta y is going to be r
sine theta
and then the z component we already said
z can be expressed as a function of y
right over here we can rewrite this as z
is equal to 2 minus y that'll tell us
how high to go so that we end up on that
plane so z is equal to 2 minus y and if
y is r sine theta we can rewrite z we
can rewrite z as being equal to
2
minus
r
sine theta so there we're done that's
our parameterization if we wanted to
write this as a but as a as a position
vector or
with two parameters and i'll call it
lowercase s since i already used r
lowercase s this is our surface and it's
going to it's going to be parameterized
with r and theta
r and theta we can write it as r cosine
theta i
plus r sine of theta j
plus
r
plus 2 minus
2 minus r
sine of theta k